I met with some home builders yesterday
from Nevada and around the country I
said is the bottom in the housing market
yet they said no we sell it a ways to go
the housing market has not reached
bottom and that's not good we know that
the financial markets are still in
turmoil they've stabilized a little bit
and that's good and maybe the rebates
that we've given will help a little bit
but we have a lot more to do we have to
do something with the housing industry
so are these kinds of problems in the
future so I think that we have to
recognize that we need a job-creating
society I think the one thing that's out
there that should be done and could be
done if we had the support of the
president his move to alternative energy
renewables Sun when Jill thermal we
would we would create millions of new
jobs and not only that may have an
economy I'm an environment that's
cleaner and more pure
you